lawyers for rapper Meek Mill say they
are confident his 2008 drug and weapons
conviction will be overturned after
attorneys on both sides requested a new
trial during a hearing yesterday Mills
lawyers cited credibility concerns about
Reginald Graham he's the officer who
testified against him now they say he is
on the Philadelphia District Attorney's
internal Do Not Call list they also
accuse the presiding judge of being
biased against mill which he denies we
recently sat down with him in his
hometown of Philadelphia you have a
judge who's against you seemingly in a
corrupt cop yeah you thinking how do I
ever survive or get out of this
there's no survivor now I think I just
was the lucky one I didn't find out to
the about the corrupt part until 2018
and when that was investigated by
investigators hired by my side
Reggie Graham happened to be one of the
cops one and it was just like a miracle
and not just for my sake everyone that
he arrested was questionable from there
or not
now we reach out to Graham for comment
we have not heard back there was also
issues with the judge in the case he
told us the story about being called
back to the judge's chambers and she was
asking him to give her give her a
shout-out on his next record and code
her in it I mean layers of the judge of
course denies that but Meek Mill says he
has witnesses to that you know there are
layers upon layers in this particular
case but for the first time
his attorneys feel that something will
be different this time around you have
both sides asking for a new trial you
actually hear that that's very unusual
exactly